you
hello and welcome from the Royal Swedish
Academy of Sciences where we've just
discovered who's received the 2010
sparox Bank Prize in Economic Sciences
in memory of Alfred Nobel with me to
discuss this prize is Professor pear
crew cell member of the economics prize
committee professor Cassell thanks very
much for talking to us could we begin by
you telling us who's received this
year's Prize in Economic Sciences yes it
was awarded to Peter diamond who was at
MIT in the United States
Dale Mortensen who was at Northwestern
in the United States and Christopher
pizzerias who is at London School of
Economics and what did they receive the
prize for the official line is for their
analysis of markets with search
frictions to understand this prize we
have to understand the dynamics of the
labor market so could you in simple
terms
tell us what search frictions are and
what their impact is on the labor market
right so search frictions exist in many
markets but as you know that the most
important example is the labor market
and in the labor market the search
frictions show up because workers are
looking for jobs that are suitable to
them and this is a process that takes
time
similarly employers are looking for
potential workers and they also are
looking for specific workers and so this
process of matching the two together is
referred to as friction search frictions
and that's that's an important element
behind why we have unemployment because
when it takes time you will have
unemployed workers and vacancies
unfilled jobs so search frictions is
that time and resources it it's it needs
to to fill fill job hosts and for people
to apply for posts and be interviewed
and for jobs to be accepted exactly so
it because that process takes time the
laureates thought in this 1970s and we
just heard professor Pisa readers this
describe how he started in the 70s with
an interest in understanding why the
unemployment rate was going up so fast
in many European countries so he thought
we have to think about this it's a huge
problem it's a social problem what
determines why it's going up so fast and
and he discovered that there was no
fully appropriate theory for thinking
about how the unemployment rate was
determined as a result of this costly
search so he started working on that and
and Peter diamond and Dale Mortensen did
the same thing on the other side of the
Atlantic so you said there was no sort
of real theories describe what was going
on what did economists think before the
three laureates published their their
groundbreaking work I think the idea
that there have been that there are
frictions the idea has perhaps been
around but it had not been developed
into a coherent complete theory to
really think about all the important
components in the labor market so one is
the worker perspective and the firm
perspective another one is how they're
matched together and the third one is
whether this market works well or or not
and and I think these questions were
mainly not addressed so they have their
work has allowed us to think coherently
about all these important issues
suppose the labor market perceived by
colonists to be like any normal supply
and demand market I think a bit more
like that this is not the only possible
theory of unemployment I mean you can
imagine that for some reason wages are
too high and then that will create
unemployment and then we have to think
about why they're too high but I think
it was the first full theory of
unemployment and how it evolves over
time because of search frictions so
could you take us through the the key
insights that the 3lauras provided in
terms of understanding such frictions in
the labor market
sure so Peter diamond was probably in
some sense the most influential one
early on because he he wrote a very
influential article in the early
seventies where he argued that even
Barry's
search costs can actually create rather
large changes in the markets in a way
that I think economists for sure had not
understood so that generated a lot of
work in this area but at the same time
Mortensen had started working on it as
well and Peter diamond then went to the
efficiency question and studied that you
know our markets efficient what can the
government do about it and that he did
over a period of 10-15 years and I think
meanwhile Mortensen and somewhat later
pianist started working more seriously
on the labor board market application so
they built up to what is now a standard
model that all graduate students and all
the policy makers in this area can know
about and have as a key tool for
understanding Policy Analysis you
mentioned the standard model that's
that's applied but could you give us
examples of how this exploit how its
applied and what insights it gives us
about to say for example the labor
market nowadays right so I mean when
when when say the Ministry of we're in
charge of labor market issues wants to
think about unemployment benefits should
they increase them should they not
should they decrease them and it goes up
and down in different countries then
systematically what are the effects of
that and the diamond Mortenson piece
sorry this model as we call it has been
used to show quite clearly that
increased unemployment benefits through
several channels tends to lead to higher
unemployment rates so you can actually
see very clearly by just having the
complete picture the way they have
served it up for us
then of course the next step is to ask
if it's desirable to doing to in this
case it would be decrease that
unemployment benefit because that would
lower the unemployment rate but then one
has to think about the unemployed
workers if you lower the benefits it's
it's bad for those who are unemployed
and that's of course a trade-off
so before you make policy changes you
have to also consider other aspects like
their insurance aspect so I think
policymakers you
the model to really highlight this this
important aspects of of the the choice
of that particular instrument but it's
similar with other changes in labor
market regulations you can sort of feed
them through the model and analyze the
outcome and you mentioned that towards
the beginning that they the models also
used in other situations you mentioned
in the announcement that the housing
market was was was one situation has
used that could you give us a bit more
detail about how it's used and what
information it provides right so the
housing market is not the example right
because we all care about much more than
just the price of a house we want to we
wanted to have certain characteristics
and qualities that we like so there's a
bunch of people searching for a house
for a home and a bunch of sellers who
would like to sell their house and this
takes time so that sort of fits the
general description first of all
secondly the in the housing market there
are some interesting things like
seasonal fluctuations I think is an
interesting aspect so you can notice
that in the fall when school starts
there's a lot of houses for sale and a
lot of people are looking for houses
there's actually even a little bit of a
seasonal variation in the price so the
price is a little bit higher certain
parts of the year and in a traditional
market this would be arbitrage the way
by investors they would make sure if
they know the price is going up they're
going to buy and make money but because
of the search frictions it doesn't
really happen and we can understand now
how it's possible with certain seasonal
patterns in an asset like like a home so
I think a it fits the description of
search frictions and B there's some some
some phenomena in this market that I
think are well described if you think
about this this from a search
perspective so employment and
unemployment and house prices these are
all very relevant very timely issues
around this climate of economic
uncertainty that we have right now was
the timeliness of this one of the
reasons why the price is more than this
year
no we our decisions are not meant to
pick up on events that happen recently I
mean they all the prices that we award
our long run efforts of the committee to
do to award important economic research
that help help us in society and stand
the world better and make the world
better and as you can understand this
has also been research that's been going
on since 70s and and there's there's no
specific there's no specific aim of the
committee to influence the situation
right now but was there any sort of
compelling developments or or
applications of this model which would
have made it a much more sort of
dominant case for selection this year
that's a good it's a good question I
think over the last 10 years the DMP
model the the diamond motors in Pisa
Rita's framework really has has had a
lot of success in entering
macroeconomics in a way it hadn't
perhaps previously so I think over the
last 10 to 15 years it's become a
cornerstone of how macro economists
analyze the macro economy of which labor
markets and unemployment it's really a
key piece so I think in that sense it
sometimes takes time before a framework
sinks in and becomes broadly used and I
think that that's that's true that
that's such a development that that is
important and my final question is did
you get a chance to speak to three
laureates well one of them was on his
way to to his home in an airplane so we
couldn't we discussed the possibility of
trying to reach him in the airplane but
decided against it but yes I've spoken
to two they're Mortensen and two crispy
sadist both of them and what was their
reaction they they were of course very
happy and shocked at the same time so
I've been been in this situation before
calling up laureates and and it was
about an average year they were happy
and
humble and but you can hear that they're
very excited too so professor Chris L
thank you very much for more information
about this prize please visit Nobel
Prize org and to receive regular news
updates from nobel-prize org please
visit our Facebook and Twitter channels
that's about it from this live webcast
and indeed a webcast of all the 2010
prize announcements our next live
webcast will be in December where we
will be showing all the Nobel lectures
and the prize award ceremony but until
then goodbye from all the team at Nobel
Prize org
you